doing underwater archeology anywhere is  a complex administrative endeavor you  ready all right I'm going in  [Music]  it was the primary burial place for the  kings and Pharaohs of the 25th dynasty  and it's descendants from about 650 to  300 BC well like all archaeology you dig  because you don't know what's there and  if you had several feet of water on top  of it put it underneath the pyramid you  have a special set of considerations  none of which we knew entirely what they  were so it was difficult to understand  in advance what the right equipment was  for example but if we had a problem  diving here there's only one entry and  exit it's a tomb door that had to be  shored up we had to make a substantial  steel chute we use something like 50  linear feet of steel i-beams  [Music]  [Music]  I don't see any way to describe it other  [Music]  [Music]